at some point you have to wonder when
ESPN and its parent company Disney when
they step in here here is Aaron Rogers
on the Pat McAfee show going after
Kimmel and then we'll show you a CNN
response to that you know mentioned ior
meon being horse based and pushed that
whole narrative for a long time he gave
a platform to one of the biggest uh
spreaders of misinformation during the
covid times Dr
fouchy um so in my opinion jeez you know
he written about RI me about the vax and
and that turns out to be an L on on many
occasions because the vax was not safe
and effective like we were told that it
was in the beginning uh there are a lot
of injuries now that we've seen related
to the vaccine so in my opinion you went
after me that's fine you're a comedian
go for it not offended but that was an
lell putting everything I've discussed
so far aside this concept that what is
happening now on ESPN shows and on
Sports shows are constant debates over
vaccines and race and everything else
that's partly why Sports as a whole why
the MLB the NBA even NFL I think
although a little lesser extent to the
NFL that the ratings have collapsed on
all of these things because we are so
sidetracked from talking about sports or
watching people do exceptional things on
the field and the court and in said
we're always talking about the political
version of that but anyway they're going
back and forth on all of this and now I
want to connect it to the to that wider
Stratosphere I mentioned uh here is
CNN's Oliver Darcy now this guy Oliver
Darcy he has tried to cancel me many
times he's gone after Joe Rogan he's
just sort of like a stooge for the
machine he goes on CNN and he's like a
media Watchdog so he's sort of like
Brian stelter light I actually think he
used to occasionally sit in for stelter
uh and watch what he does here he he
lays the pressure into Disney because of
course Disney's connected to this too
because Disney owns ESPN and much like
they wreck Star Wars they W wrecked ESPN
uh here is CNN's media Watchdog Oliver
Darcy putting pressure on Disney to
basically fire Pat mcae who's the host
of that show that Aaron Rogers was on of
course what Rogers is saying there is is
just not true the medical community
would have course say that the vaccine
was both safe and effective and at some
point you have to wonder when ESPN and
its parent company Disney when they step
in here you know uh Disney's at this
point one of the only uh major media
companies outside maybe Fox News that
would would allow this sort of danger
uh
antivaccine medical misinformation to be
aired unchecked on their air and this
isn't the first time Rogers has done
this you know he goes on these extended
rants during his weekly appearance on
the Pat McAfee show which is aired on
ESPN but for now ESPN and Disney they're
they're staying silent and not
commenting what a little buge eyed freak
yes the vaccines are safe and effective
the medical community believes that the
vaccines are safe and effective and it's
only Disney owned ESPN that allows this
besides Fox you see what they're trying
to do this is exactly what they were
doing with Rogan a year and a half ago
when they were all trying to cancel
Rogan over the nword which he never said
pejoratively he was always saying to
make fun of the people who are the
actual racists what they do is they go
oh there is competition out there people
are tuning out of our nonsense they're
suddenly watching ESPN and getting more
sane political analysis from Aaron
roders than they're getting here on our
Network so we better put pressure on
Disney to fire Pat McAfee for having
that conversation we better make sure
the fox can't get any advertisers
because they're scary
too